hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about uh Hines basic 57 so
uh please don't sue me hindes catchup
but uh these are my 57 techniques with
the exception of the showman series that
I use to teach my students formal iido
um and we're going to talk about ushiro
rata and so the three techniques I show
from that are ID Minag KAG and iot to
now again it's not that um there aren't
there's tons of other techniques right
and and it's not that we don't do those
techniques in the school it's that in
respect to this total list if you know
the totality of the list you will learn
the other bits of those other ushiro
riio catador techniques in other forms
and these are a little more
quintessential for me and I think
they're learned best in this so there's
only three techniques forio catador and
again not that that's all we teach but
just for the formal techniques I'm going
to get Josh over here you're going to to
work Josh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's talk about usir rata and
the three forms that I consider the
formal forms for it I can't emphasize
this enough there are tons of perfectly
acceptable great iido techniques but
these three forms are are pretty much
the the things that are like forms that
you need to know that are unique in in
this and um understand this also comes
from a bigger set of other stuff and
we've talked before about how sh real
Cota might happen um but you know if we
were talking about the hoki for Josh
right okay so know my basic hoki for uh
usir Riata is to cut to the outside
that's my basic one right and when I do
that let me go to the other side for you
guys too so you can see when I do that I
really want to pull this shoulder free
and push this shoulder free and that's
my basic my basic form and that's going
to be the simplest easiest thing to do
when he's driving you on a line it's
going to be the easiest way to keep your
balance and all this other stuff right
okay now if I choose to go to a
direction and he shoots his arm out that
side I can't get out right so see he's
shooting his arm out so he can't get out
so that enables me to have inside action
right so I get this udashi is what we
call it just to go around the arms and
that gives us inside action for that
right okay now if I'm doing those back
and forth he really I'm going to
actually try to catch him in one of
those either turning to the outside or
turning to the inside but what he could
do is he could pull me in really really
tight and if he pulls me in really tight
I can't get those because I'm all stuck
up here so that's where our CAG comes in
and then he could also shove Me Away
really really hard so I can't get either
of those he's really strong and that's
where ikio to comes in right so that's
that's my four set for hoki that I use
and students get that Prett pretty early
I expect you to see that at uh 7th Q so
um you're going to get that pretty early
but then extensions of that is to get a
full form right and so we have three for
the full form okay now we have edim
Minag which you don't see in the hoki
and the edim Minag is really hard to do
um kids are better at taking you Kim for
this not hard to do for nag easy to do
for nag but hard to do for the adults
because you have to have real
flexibility in your arms and you have to
have a pretty good grip and so if you're
really light right so the kids weigh you
know 70 80 lbs whatever right they could
a little just a little bigger right
can't can't be a jockey yet but anyway
so um the kids are light so they're
grips more than adequate and they're
usually really flexible so that it's
easy for them to stay on this but most
adults you'll break free before this so
I attempt my outside turn right now as I
do that I feel that he's going to stay
stuck with me so I'm going to shoot all
the way around it right now most people
right here will break right so when I go
like this most people are going to break
free that's just the way it's going to
be but some people who are flexible will
manage to stick on and they can stick on
all the way to this EDI position right
and you see Josh doesn't have the
flexibility for it I don't anymore
either um but uh if they could really
stay stuck the edium position is what
comes out of that now we have an ed
Minag there because if they manage to
stick on that long their balance is
going to be shot and so that is the
thing to do but if you just worried
about clearing grips then you get there
and you go oh what do I do he's still
holding on it's like well you just e
imag them is what you do it's really
simple but um that's why that is one of
the forms that we use okay then the
other two are included in the hoki but
they're also full forms and they're
really important for this and that is
the the cou Nugget where he pulls me in
really tight right and so he's done most
of the work here he pulled me in really
tight so all I'm doing is stepping
behind him and trying to find an
imbalance in there in that tightness
okay and the full form is just simply he
pulls in I go in boom
CAG okay and the ikio Tosh he drives me
forward I dive down I pull and cut right
back towards him uh and I make a iOS in
that right and so we call ikos anytime
um that uh the I key action so what he's
doing and I match with it is what makes
him fall down so in that he drives me uh
and I go with it and he falls down so
that's the ikos so those are the three
forms I show for usir Riata understand
that's coming to students at third Q
after a long time of developing the hoki
for it and working with it live and all
kinds of other stuff so um those three
forms are just kind of a little little
last polish on that um so those are the
three forms for usir Rio cador I'm
Christopher Hines Joshua te myON
McDaniels behind that camera right there
[Music]